so you go to the doctor and get some
tests doctor determines that you have
high cholesterol and you would benefit
from medication to treat it so you get a
pill box you have some confidence your
physician has some confidence that this
is going to work the company that
invented it did a lot of studies
submitted it to the FDA they studied it
very carefully skeptically they approved
it they have a rough idea of how it
works they have a rough idea of what the
side effects are it should be okay you
have a little bit more of a conversation
with your physician and the physician is
a little worried because you've been
blue you haven't felt like yourself you
haven't been able to enjoy things in
life quite as much as you usually do
physician says you know I think you have
some depression going to have to give
you another pill so now we're talking
about two medications this pill also
millions of people have taken it company
did studies FDA looked at it all good
think things should go okay think things
should go okay well wait a minute how
much have we studied these two together
well it's very hard to do that in fact
it's not traditionally done we totally
depend on what we call post marketing
surveillance after the drugs hit the
market how can we figure out if bad
things are happening between two
medications three five seven ask your
favorite person who has several
diagnoses how many medications they're
on so why do I care about this problem I
care about it deeply I'm an informatics
and data science guy and really in my
opinion the only hope only hope to
understand these interactions is to
leverage lots of different sources of
data in order to figure out when drugs
can be used together safely and when
it's not so safe so let me tell you a
data science story and it begins with my
student Nick let's call him Nick because
that's his name
Nik was a young student and I said you
know Nick we have to understand how
drugs work and how and how they work
together and how they work separately
and we don't have a great understanding
but the FDA has made available an
amazing database it's a database of
adverse events they literally put on the
web publicly available you could all
download it right now hundreds of
thousands of adverse event reports from
patients doctors companies pharmacists
and and these reports are pretty simple
it has all the diseases that the patient
has all the drugs that they're on and
all the adverse events or side effects
that they experienced it is not all of
the adverse events that are occurring in
America today but it's hundreds and
hundreds of thousands of drugs so I said
to Nick let's think about glucose
glucose is very important and we know
it's involved with diabetes let's see if
we can understand a glucose response
sent Nick off Nick came back Russ he
said I've created a classifier that can
look at the side effects of a drug based
on looking at this database and can tell
you whether that drug is likely to
change glucose or not he did it was very
simple in a way he took all the drugs
that were known to change glucose and he
took a bunch of drugs that don't change
glucose and he said what's the
difference in their side effects
differences in fatigue in appetite in
urination habits all those things
conspire to give him a really good
predictor he said Russ I can predict
with 93% accuracy when a drug will
change glucose and I said Nick that's
great you know he's a young student you
have to build this confidence but Nick
there's a problem it's that every
physician in the world knows all the
drugs that change glucose because it's
core to our practice so it's it's great
you know good job but not really that
interesting definitely not publishable
he said I know Russ I thought you might
say snick is smart I thought you might
say that Russ so I did one other
experiment I looked at people in this
database who were on to drugs and I
looked for signals similar glucose
changing signals for people taking two
drugs where each drug alone did not
change glucose but together I saw a
strong signal
I said oh you're clever good idea show
me the list and has a bunch of drugs
that not very exciting but what caught
my eye were on a list there were two
drugs paroxetine or paxil an
antidepressant and pravastatin or
private call a cholesterol medication
and I said huh there are millions of
Americans on those two drugs in fact we
learned later 15 million Americans on
paroxetine at the time
15 million on pravastatin and a million
we estimated on both sets a million
people who might be having some problems
with their glucose if this machine
learning mumbo jumbo that he did in the
FDA database actually holds up but I
said Nick it's still not publishable
because you know I love what you did
with the mumbo jumbo with the machine
learning but it's not really standard of
proof evidence that we have so we have
to do something else let's go into the
stanford electronic medical record we
have a copy of it that's okay for
research we removed identifying
information and I said let's see if
people on these two drugs have problems
with their glucose now there are
thousands and thousands of people in the
Stanford medical records that take
paroxetine and pravastatin but we needed
special patients we needed patients who
are on one of them and had a glucose
measurement then got the second one and
had another glucose measurement all
within a reasonable period of time
something like two months and when you
did that we found ten patients however
eight out of the ten had a bump in their
glucose when they got the second P we
call this P and P when they got the
second P either one could be first
second one comes up glucose went up
twenty milligrams per deciliter just as
a reminder you walk around normally if
you're not diabetic with a glucose of
around 90 and if it gets up to 120 125
your doctor begins to think about a
potential diagnosis of diabetes so a 20
bump pretty significant I said Nick this
is very cool but I'm sorry we still
don't have a paper because this is 10
patients and kind of give me a break
it's not enough patients and so we said
well what can we do and we said well
let's call our friends at Harvard and
Vanderbilt who also Harvard and Boston
Vanderbilt in Nashville who also have
chronic medical records similar to ours
let's see if they can find similar
patients with the one P the other P the
glucose measurements in that range that
we need god bless him
Vanderbilt in one week found 40 such
patients same trend Harvard found a
hundred patients same trend so at the
end we had 150 patients from three
diverse medical centers that were
telling us that patients getting these
two drugs were having their glucose bump
somewhat significantly more
interestingly we had left out diabetics
because diabetics already have messed up
glucose when we looked at the glucose of
diabetics it was going up 60 milligrams
per deciliter not just 20 this was a big
deal and we said we got to publish this
we submitted the paper it was all data
evidence data from the FDA data from
Stanford data from Vanderbilt data from
Harvard we had not done a single real
experiment but we were nervous so Nick
while the paper was in review went to
the lab we found somebody who knew about
lab stuff I don't do that I take care of
patients but I don't do pipettes they
taught us how to feed mice drugs
we took mice and we gave them one pea
paroxetine we gave some other mice
pravastatin and we gave a third group of
mice and some of both of them and lo and
behold glucose went up 20 to 60
milligrams per deciliter in the mice so
the paper was accepted based on the
informatics evidence alone but we added
a little note at the end saying oh by
the way if you give these two mice goes
up that was great and the story could
have ended there but I still have six
and a half minutes
so we were sitting around thinking about
all this and I don't remember who
thought of it but somebody said I wonder
if patients who are taking these two
drugs are noticing side-effects of
hyperglycemia they could and they should
how would we ever determine that we said
well what do you do if you're taking a
medication one new medication or two and
you get a funny feeling what are you
going to do you're going to go to Google
and you're going to type in the two
drugs you're taking or the one drug
you're taken and you're type in side
effects
what are you experiencing so we said
okay let's ask Google if they will share
their search logs with us so that we can
look at the search logs and see if
patients are doing these kinds of
searches Google I am sorry to say denied
our request so I was bummed and I was at
a dinner with a colleague who works at
Microsoft Research and I said hey we
want to do this study Google said no
it's kind of a bummer he said well we
have the Bing searches yeah that's great
you know now I felt like I was I felt
like I was talking to nikodem you know
he works for one of the largest
companies in the world and I'm already
trying to make him feel better but he
said no rest he said you might not
understand we not only have Bing
searches but if you use Internet
Explorer to do searches at Google Yahoo
Bing any then for 18 months we keep that
data for research purposes only I said
no no now you're talking this was Eric
Horvitz my friend at Microsoft so we did
a study where we defined 50 words that a
regular person might type in if they're
having hyperglycemia like fatigue loss
of appetite urinating a lot peeing a lot
forgive me but that's one thing you
might type in so we had 50 phrases that
we call the diabetes words and we did up
first a baseline and it turns out that
about 0.5 to 1 percent of all searches
on the internet involve one of those
words so that's our baseline rate if
people type in paroxetine or paxil those
are synonyms and one of those words the
rate goes up to about 2% of diabetes
type words if you already know that
there's that a paroxetine word
if it's pravastatin the rate goes up to
about three percent from the baseline
if both paroxetine and pravastatin are
present in the query it goes up to ten
percent a huge fourfold three to
fourfold increase in those searches with
the two drugs that we were interested in
and kind of diabetes type words or
hyperglycemia type words we published
this and it got some attention the
reason it deserves attention is patients
are telling us their side effects
indirectly through their searches we
brought this to the attention of the FDA
they were interested they have set up
social media surveillance programs to
kind of collaborate with Microsoft which
had a nice infrastructure for doing this
and others to look at Twitter feeds to
look at Facebook feeds to look at search
logs to try to see early signs that
drugs either individually or together or
causing problems so what do I take from
this why do I tell this story well first
of all we have now the promise of big
data and medium sized data to help us
understand drug interactions and really
fundamentally drug actions how do drugs
work this will create and has created a
new ecosystem for understanding how
drugs work and to optimize their use
Nick went on he's a professor at
Columbia now he did this in his PhD for
hundreds of pairs of drugs found several
very important interactions and so we
replicated this and we showed that this
is a way that really works for finding
drug drug interactions however there's a
couple of things we don't just use pairs
of drugs at a time as I said before
there are patients on three five seven
nine drugs have they been studied with
respect to their nine way interaction
yes we can do pairwise a and B a and C a
and D but what about ABCD efg all
together being taken by the same patient
perhaps interacting with each other in
ways that either makes them more
effective or less effective or causes
side effects that are unexpected we
really have no idea it's a blue sky open
field for us to use data to try to
understand the interaction of drugs two
more lessons
I want you to think about the power that
we were able to generate with the data
from people who had volunteered their
adverse reactions through their
pharmacists through themselves through
their doctors the people who allowed the
databases at Stanford Harvard Vanderbilt
to be used for research people are
worried about data they're worried about
their privacy and their security they
should be we need secure systems but we
can't have a system that closes that
data off because it is too rich of a
source of inspiration innovation and
discovery for new things in medicine and
then the final thing I want to say is in
this case we found two drugs and it was
a little bit of a sad story the two
drugs actually caused problems they
increase glucose they could throw
somebody into diabetes who would
otherwise just be not in diabetes and so
you would want to use the two drugs very
carefully together perhaps not together
used to make different choices when
you're prescribing but there was another
possibility we could have found two
drugs or three drugs that were
interacting in a beneficial way we could
have found new effects of drugs that
neither of them has alone but together
instead of causing a side effect they
could be a new and novel treatment for
diseases that don't have treatments or
where the treatments are not effective
if we think about drug treatment today
all the major breakthroughs for HIV for
tuberculosis for depression for diabetes
it's always a cocktail of drugs and so
the upside here and the subjects for a
different TED talk on a different day is
how can we use the same data sources to
find good effects of drugs in
combination that will provide us new
treatments new insights into how drugs
work and it enabled us to take care of
our patients even better thank you very
much